okay well for people who join in this
live stream this is one of our infinite
series of meetings discussing
incremental development in Wolff
language and we have apparently three
small items and one big item to discuss
today so first small item has to do with
this retry option yes
so the idea we killed this idea last
time
well the what we killed is the idea of
having a separate function for it but
you suggested that we explore this in
relation as an option or two to URL
reads excetera
okay so Ricardo has some idea there at
the end and also Francisco's here for
the discussion from the point of view of
connections both from alpha consider
okay so that was the original idea and
so we are exploring now the possibility
of having a retried option mm-hmm and
the question is what would be the syntax
for the retrial well so this is a retry
function that would be a retry function
for things like URL read write is Fahim
here by any chance
I asked for him and he said Ricardo is
the relevant person to be yes he's here
yes yes okay so what are you proposing
here it's very easy basically you know
most of the time you will need to retry
the the response if something out okay
this is we want to rewrite either the
live is a server error and if it's a
server error you want retry it maybe
with incremental time and so this
function credit return like toward fall
so we could return a time basically a
date object anyone that redragon
but actually this cannot really
happening in this code because you need
to rewrite synchronously
so he's just say yes or no in this case
we're looking at two different things
we're looking at I mean we've got URLs
submit which is an asynchronous thing
you know one thing that can happen is
asynchronously you know you're trying to
get something returned from a URL the
the server you know has it's it's not
returning stuff um but then you want to
keep going later somebody is making a
very weird noise on the phone here um
okay um
so that's that case URL read is a
synchronous read right
it's a blocking synchronous read yes
okay so what are you proposing here for
this function just through and false I
don't know if is possible to implement
for you or else um meet something else
than just to enforce the question for
URL read is should it be retried right
the question mm-hmm but you're saying
without it without a pause or you're
saying with a pause without a post that
is true yeah I mean maybe in a in a
synchronous environment maybe it doesn't
makes that much sense now that that
we're thinking about it because if this
effort was down then the store yeah I
mean unless it got routed and that's
that particular you know request got
routed in some weird way or something
like that
I mean you know we perfectly well okay
so we all we have a time constraint
don't we in URL read I mean the
the keys were basically 500 zeros you
might want to retry them for like three
or four times and if the server keeps
returning an error then you know
sometimes it just happened for example
like a get away error and then basically
what happened is that the underlying
service is not responding like I don't
know Apache he cannot find you know
Python or know the design running
underground okay can happen but it's
true that you know basically after four
or five times they do it synchronously
doesn't make that much sense to to keep
retrying synchrony you you know you want
to but that's already okay look the
various possibilities here one thing we
could have is a thing called max retries
right in addition to time constraint
which we have here right in in you know
URL read right now we have no retries we
never have a retry right so max retries
by default will be one right in which if
you don't provide a function of the
result then you will need to describe
what are the uses you are trying and I
guess sensible case will be you know if
the server is returning 5-0 kind of
errors two things okay so you're saying
we need to know what counts as a failure
threat and how many times to retry which
is why I was thinking about them in life
okay and there's a third thing which is
how long to wait between each retry but
you got a three do it I mean you could
also wait so what okay that calls us for
example if you see the man page of core
mm-hmm I put that in the some chat and
search for - - right right you have
their four options too so they've
already invented yes but they don't
expose that in the library by the way
that's why we don't have that in Euros
fetch and family so this is something
they have in the client in the cool
client the number of retries how much
time to wait and how much time to wait
between retries and something else that
I think we will need is what consider to
be a failure that might be right right
yes
the case where I think a function will
be the value for that option and the
others will be the same constant number
etc I think that could be easily you
setting any almost in any case I think
okay so time consider we currently have
time constraint which is similar to
this spread which is the overall time
that you can possibly you know that
that's the that's the well it's not
really the same time constrain is along
you wait before considering a time out
so deserve very deserve it might be
saying yeah this is the response but now
it takes minutes or something and you
might yeah
but time constrain you know it up it
happens the the server is responding is
just as much time and yeah okay so one
possibility that we could have is you
know we could consider something like
retry rules and it's an association
which contains a bunch of different
things um you know we could consider you
know what are they called the the 501
think is 500 what is that cold what is
the category of thing which 500 is you
know back into errors no no I mean what
is the code right right right right
right
um you know it's kind of like what do
you consider to be success what do you
consider to be failure I mean there's a
bunch of
from things here and that would be I
mean rather than giving a function where
you have to have all kinds of you know
code that one Chris you know not really
I mean the response if you just ask for
the status code gets back to the status
code and then just say you know if
status code created them forever that
will return the true or false and
attempt nowhere then you know I it's a
synthetic and kind of easy call instead
of I'm the specification and and it's
rather more powerful to have a function
that can actually inspect the whole
response so okay so you're proposing
that it says retry function but
unfortunately that word means that's the
function to use to retry that's I mean
really what it is more is this is a test
for whether to retry am I making sense
or just three try tests hmm what are you
proposing then is the actual you're
proposing as a function which takes what
as its arguments what you can do is
basically ash status code greater than
500 and as to lower than four like yeah
no but this isn't giving the pores right
this is this is just to a false but that
should be complementary to other options
regarding this retrial number of times
retro etc so I will use the rest right
condition only to test the HTTP response
so that in case you have you want
something more advanced like inspecting
the content the actual content you can
use that etc so you're suggesting that
there's a retry pause which is just you
know how many seconds or whatever
usually dry it's you know exponential
yes right I mean yeah okay so how do we
represent that I mean here then this
might return you know how soon to retry
right if you return non or false that
could be stopped it otherwise you return
a time otherwise you're out of time
right I mean it's a little bit of a
weird thing retry time function
well okay retry time function - none
means don't retry
retry time function to a number yeah
sure zero yeah return will be immediate
and n will be seconds I guess and then
you can use quantities I don't think so
I mean retry time function I was
thinking that means the number of times
to retry in that case that's a short
time for a number of times to retry oh
say we rate the function from that yeah
sure
otherwise the the arguments are the the
arguments to the function are the return
value the most recent return
and
the serial number of that return see one
thing we could do
when we return something when we return
the packet why not return that serial
number in the packet or is that crazy
your read returns an HTTP response right
can be that I could be a property yes it
could be a profit so yeah in the second
argument even say retry number or
something what would that actually be so
that would be part of HTTP response
right no no no that would be just a
probability of your L read I guess why
it is not really part of the response
well we want inside yeah so my grant is
metadata yeah
yes is really strictly not part of the
response yeah yeah I agree we should not
include anything related to different
right to the response you know it does
it doesn't quite seem right but okay so
then the idea is this returns a you know
a time time to retry time to pause
before retrying
okay so in the exponential back-off it
will be 2 to the power serial number or
something like this
right right is this useful I mean it's
this whole thing useful do you think
retry time function it seems somewhat
useful I mean you will need to implement
it yourself if you if you if you want to
retry but I feel it's a bit complicated
for for the most common cases where you
only want like 5 times to retry or
that's what I want this case for that's
why I'm saying do this retry time
function are of five yeah but also if
you just return true there or zero that
would mean you know retry synchronously
five times just in I'm just saying the
function yes this is one the sense here
and what I'm also saying that you know
also from the function is pretty easy to
do that you just need to return you know
small small number like zero okay so the
other possibility would be retry time
function so it seems to me the two sort
of courtesy cases are that and the
quantity case where you can give a time
yeah but then how many times good
question until you reach the total thing
note how many times you retry with that
one I mean ya know as you can assume one
but no no no no you keep going until you
hit the time constraint but but Divac
receives for a single request yes I was
wondering if it's so right now time
constraint is for a single request
because we are not retraining yes
so how are we going to interpret the
tank in the case where you still got to
know how long to wait for a single
request
before you try a retry
so I agree that we need a parameter that
determines how long to wait for a single
request right
yeah and that that will be done
constrained okay so this one is single
request
so there's no overall if it's larger
than this amount of time I mean arguably
what we could do here is we could have
serial number and we could have total
time so far as a third argument I think
on special leave only for single
requests you have to specify how long to
wait for a single request no I agree but
but what I mean is that time constraint
is used in many other cases as always
meaning the total time for that function
you're right
so that would suggest that we need a or
we can reuse also we have other timeout
options in neural fetch like for example
connecting Maori time out this this
quantity stuff is not really useful if
it's knowledge in anyways I think does
not work if it's not exponential it's
not useful and you can express like
easily with a function and we actually
make you know the first a couple of
examples that people can just copy a
change I'm not clear the claim that
there are timeouts
I'm not seeing a timeout oh time
constraint oh gosh look at that
look at that we've got a more elaborated
time constraint here
so we perfectly well could have
something in time constraint called
total
which could be the default do you see
what I'm saying
right because time constraint right now
has an association which breaks down the
time to connect the time to read make
sense
mm-hmm anybody got any idea where I can
put this do you know solution I do know
if we have we have a folder called
language functions if you want to put
this no no I don't want to put it in
something to do with URL I don't know if
they I don't think so we have any
folders Victor Wow okay weird
I'm going to somewhat
unreasonably put it in
oh dear where should it go
I'm gonna put in an import-export and
you're gonna remember that it's there
okay no actually this is I hate to put
something in miscellaneous I can't even
imagine what would be in miscellaneous
well okay I'll put it in miscellaneous
okay um under retry function okay okay
so let's loop back
what are we concluding here okay so in
here we consider the possibility of
saying you know total gosh this has to
be broken into per request and do you
get what I'm saying something like all
requests are oh whatever
and another request in case you want no
one connecting and ringing separate yes
I know that would be just the sum of
town
connecting and reading that's correct
but if you if you do right so that will
be the the thing with that spur request
is the sum of connecting reading all
requests is the timeout allowed so you
can have so I mean okay so that's that
will be a possibility for that then here
what we're suggesting is retry time
function which returns the time to pause
before retrying or
none if you don't want to retry is that
right right okay okay well this seems
reasonable who who would implement this
we'll be either me or one maybe
who won the remember the last name okay
is it Easy Street URL fetch takes
multiple requests so it's just matter of
you know filtering out the one that
failed then keep redrawing and return
yeah
just okay so question um what about URL
submit not sure about that
unfortunately we will need to ask to
Constantine okay all right well why
don't you do that and let's consider
this you know this is not the highest
priority thing but let's try to keep
this moving forward sure okay okay thank
you okay see ya okay next up next date
taking day names wow what an earth is
this so the basic idea is there is a
suggestion than if you say next date of
Tuesday it should give you the next
Tuesday that's coming up as a date or
previous date of Tuesday it should give
you the previous Tuesday and what we
wanted to do is you know those
particular elements of it are not hard
to do but we wanted to look at the day
named functions are all related to sort
of a parent categorization of dates
which are called day types so we have
the days of the week Monday through
Sunday we have weekday weekend end of
month beginning of month and then
holiday related things and so we wanted
to apply the same basic logic to these
functions but we also needed to sort of
sort out what we want to do with current
dates because if we say current date of
Tuesday today today's not a Tuesday so
it would either have to give a date
that's not the current date or it would
have to give an error
and when Jose and I were discussing this
we felt like it's more consistent for it
to just give an error in those cases
rather than arbitrarily that's crazy to
just say I mean in other words next date
of Tuesday seems to me to make some
sense I mean in other words so next date
so for example what happens if you say
next day to weekend so right now we
don't support these particular
parameters but we're in loi attending
that to be a granularity like day and
month or a year so all of these day
types have a granularity of day that
that's where you know the original
version of next a previous date and
current they all take granularities but
they don't take things like day types
because day types are all a day they're
just a particular qualification for a
day and okay but wait a minute if I say
next day to a weekend do I get the date
interval that corresponds to the whole
weekend should I get the data interval
corresponding to the whole weekend I
don't think so because I think the the
the implicit granularity of all of these
is a day next date of weekend is saying
give me the next day that's on the
weekend so if you did it right now it
would give you this coming Saturday if
you evaluated it on this coming Sunday
it would give you the following Saturday
that's what they round is doing right
now
right yeah what if they round so day
round takes a date and a day type so you
can if you say day round of now it will
give you today it will basically found
it the day out which uses the current
day as the default if you said day round
now comma Friday it would give you this
coming Friday come on Friday yeah Friday
is a symbol do you mean so the second
argument is a day type you're saying I
want to round today to the nearest
Friday or by the default rounding system
which is current or following
that's really weird that seems weird I
mean if I that that is a way of getting
next Friday I mean the next up Friday
and it seems a much better way to do
that would be to say next day to Friday
yeah I think you know when we weren't
originally thinking about the day types
when we created next date in previous
day but I think you know based on the
function name and the general design it
makes a lot of sense to do that
I just wasn't as sure if we wanted to
generalize that to all of the day types
or we wanted to just say well we'll do
it four days of the week and for these
other things there I'm concerned about
what you say next date of granularity
effectively weekend that you're not
getting the whole weekend that seems
wrong sorry weekend is not a grand
rarity mm-hmm and I don't think Friday
is a granularity either right II need is
something which competition continuously
or fully the time axis we once in
principle there's no gaps in granularity
there gaps between Fridays and there
gaps between weekends or holidays but so
how would I get the span of days which
corresponds to next weekend
I mean right now we don't have a
specific function to do that I mean you
could you could set it up using a day
range or well you get a list of days
yeah
but date interval is supposed to do that
isn't it I mean D date interval is
supposed to be the symbolic
representation of a range of days yeah
but in terms of I mean most of these
date functions are set up to return a
single date and in terms of having I
guess I haven't haven't thought really
extensively about what next date of
weekend would be other than saying you
know if we want if we're treating these
not as granularities but as day type
specifications we're getting the next
day type that matches alright but we've
got two issues here one is how do we get
the beginning of next weekend and then
how do we get the rate the full interval
of next weekend mm-hmm right those are
two different things and what we're
doing with granularities right now you
know we've got the moment at which the
weekend begins this is a complete week
right right so if I say current date
yeah so that's
that's correct there mm-hmm so okay so
the issue is again we've got these two
different cases you know give the span
of the next weekend and we've also got
give the beginning of the next weekend
or give the you know beginning of the
next weekend to granularity X eg day
right mm-hmm
okay so how do we represent these
because right now next blah blah blah
next date
just takes a granularity okay and as you
say those granularities are arranged one
after another mm-hmm I mean I think what
let's see next date gives the next date
of the given we are Alera T with respect
to the risk with specified date so in a
sense there's
pseudo granularity which is interval no
there's a meta granularity which is
interval so in other words you can say
the interval of days corresponding to
the weekend or you can say the interval
of seconds corresponding to the weekend
what I'm saying
yeah I mean the the general notion of
the interval as we've conceived it thus
far is to represent a continuous period
of time it begins at one moment it ends
at another moment great but that could
be but do we also do we potentially want
date interval to also know a granularity
of things inside it we had we had talked
about potentially differentiating
between having a date interval that is
always a full collection of instance
versus a date span that could have
either a period associated with it or
granularity associated with it but the
the main sort of abstraction is that the
granularity of the date interval is more
interesting on the specific operations
that you're working on it so if you take
a date range of a date interval then you
could say I want it in this step size I
don't know if it's as useful to say this
is a date interval from this instant to
this instant
but the implied step size associated
with it is years because okay okay but
do we currently have weekend for
anything is there any is that currently
a thing so we have weekend as a day type
it's used in the various day functions
day match queue day round day count so I
have a list of those on there on your
left-hand notebook I want to find the
next weekend how can I do it so if you
do day plus of today comma weekend it
will give you the first day that matches
the criteria of weekend so it will give
Saturday oh I'm sorry one yeah and if
you add one weekend to that day it will
give you Sunday and if you add another
weekend to it it will give you the next
if I give if you give - it will give you
the Sunday or if you put three it will
jump to the next Saturday I see so
that's a criterion what day Plus that's
adding a certain number of days with a
criterion that they must be those kinds
of days correct okay which is different
from saying jump to the next one of that
thing mm-hmm
right so for example your jump to the
next Friday
okay so that would be much closer to
jump to the next so the problem is next
date
you
yes I mean to me next date of weekend
should be some kind of date span of next
weekend
because given dates plan and agent of
what we're going to have to have
functions that get us the beginning and
the end of that interval yeah I guess
the the slightly complicated thing is
when we look at the you know weekday and
weekend are used sort of in parallel
where the the name of this probably
isn't as great because weekday if you
say next date of weekday you don't
expect to get the whole span of weekdays
it's referring to a singular element
within that and really when this weekend
day right well so that's what we should
call it to not to you know so we've got
the notion of a weekend day and weekday
mm-hmm right um which are criteria then
okay so what are you proposing you're
proposing the next state okay so if we
said next state a weekend day then I
quite understand that it's going to go
to the next weekend day just like a day
plus goes to the next day that satisfies
a criterion mmm okay yeah I think that
it's okay so then then if it's next date
of so what we're now saying is it's
either a granularity so actually we need
both cases so ultimately we could have
here all right so we have the
stability of a date there but in
addition to granularity so we'll have a
granularity or we can have a a type
basically mm-hmm with a default
granularity these ones would have a
default granularity hmm of day so then
the proposal would be if it's next date
or when we could accept both the symbol
and a string as courtesy of let's say
Friday for example mm-hmm
then that would again have default
granularity of day correct
and we date a Friday if it's not a
Friday would just give an error yeah I
think that makes sense and we were we're
looking at adding a calendar granularity
option to specify granularity so we
could use that to increase the precision
of the granularity I don't think saying
next date of Friday granularity goes to
year makes any sense I mean I guess it
you you would basically it would maybe
be useful at the end of the year when
you're transitioning over and saying
well what are you saying about counter
granularity what why I mean so we had
talked about adding an option called
either date granularity or calendar
granularity which is an alternative to
giving the argument right as an
alternative to giving the argument say I
want a date range from this date to this
date but I want the outputs to be in
this granularity instead of whatever
they would be normally well yeah I think
that's reasonable enough so that um okay
and that avoids us having to add an
extra argument in to handle variation
there okay so what other things are they
that in addition to weekend day I mean
there's potentially holiday yeah there's
the holiday or business day which is a
weekday that isn't a holiday
the only one I can think of that isn't a
day type that might be useful is leap
year we have leap year queue but we
don't have a way to say give me the next
leap year I mean throw it it's pretty
straightforward to know what it is but
both of those presumably mm-hmm and then
each day of the week and then we also
have end of month beginning of month I
don't
those are all things yeah those are days
so I think um month the first day month
last day would be clearer if the default
granularity is day mm-hmm and you know
week first day well you can pick you
know Sunday Monday whatever because they
have names right yep I mean one could
imagine year first day as well that's
where it starts to get down a slippery
slope right seems like for example
second Friday of the month so those I
mean that that's when you start getting
into things like date select where you
want to either use some sort of
scheduling notation or you want to have
some general pattern to say my you know
I have either this explicit or implicit
range of dates and I want the days that
I want the second Tuesday of every month
or I want you know how do you do that
though so so that's something that we're
working on as an experimental function
for date select it's out of my queue
right now we basically use the keys
associated with date value where you can
set up a criteria we can compile it down
and then look at a range of dates and
say but how do you do the second
Tuesday whatever so in that case we we'd
need to either have something like cron
notation where we have you know division
forms which I don't think is
particularly good or we can have extra
criteria where we say you know it's
after M excuse me that it's after a
certain criteria within the month it's a
little tricky to sort of generalize the
form and say I want the the second
Tuesday of a given month well I you know
one issue is whether the Linguistics
whether we have decent you know control
equals linguistics with some of this
stuff call lying on a live stream is
asking about luna months and there's a
Horeb
well we we have the we have the
quantities for all the various types of
lunar month draconian month etc but we
don't have a way of determining the
beginning and end of them right now
although we know them ye-yes I guess we
to just buy yes compete in the position
and the moments and the earth yeah yeah
we could compute it it's just another
thing we have a syntax flame right now
but that is an interesting thing for I
mean oh boy right now I mean we could
imagine a granularity of lunar months
well we have been so far distinguishing
the units from the granularities and we
have lunar months and various types of
months as units fixed duration but not
the second right it is right the
granularities are very closely tied to
the calendar there there are
granularities that make sense in a
Gregorian calendar that may not make
sense in the islamic calendar or in the
mayans olkin calendar because they just
don't have the same unit steps okay so
where does that leave us with lunar
month for example these newer months etc
they are typically average because they
are not all exactly the same and depends
on what it's not the actual position of
the moon is what you're saying
we're not asking when does the moon
exactly that's the draconic month versus
the I forget what all of those are right
you know you know the commands etc yes
so what's your point so I mean once we
have the astronomy functions they were
able to compute all these things because
they will depend on time right now the
only thing we can offer is the average
amount stored in the unit framework I
see
so so this question about lunar month
basically we should wait until we have
the proper rest
we framework except it's gonna give us
the exact answer to when is the moon
next in this position relative to this
than that except okay but that doesn't
answer the second Tuesday of the month
the question no that's different yeah
because that's fully dependent on the
calendars Nexus and we'll have just
invent a notation for that but is that
hmm what happens if we say like the
fifth the eighth Tuesday of the month I
would just like like we do when we say
there they are hundreds of February we
compute something in May or something
maybe do the same thing okay but so what
you're saying here you know this is
month first day I mean basically hmm so
we can get you know we can get the first
weekend in March or something that's
another typical type of thing but then
we've also got I mean we've got we
support a lot of the stuff in love now
for the first Monday after Christmas
we've also got things like that yes so
computing these things is not difficult
it's simple arithmetic the problematic
thing is how to represent them we've got
de plus we'll count that gives us the
first Friday of today right right is
that what that means de plus it says
yeah yes if you try to it will give you
the next week welcome in the next Friday
yeah so that's exactly doing this right
mm-hmm
it's just that the the criteria that you
can provide is a limited set of types of
days so you know basically if we say the
first Monday after Christmas
we just need something that determines
in the first argument when Christmas is
and then +1 Monday ok so any any of
these sort of more elaborate
combinations just usually involves a
couple of steps where we compute
whatever a reference date we want is and
then we add whatever we want from there
yes um so I think the the short-term
takeaway is it's it's pretty
straightforward for us to take the the
list you have here of weekend a week day
etc turn those into arguments we can
provide to next eight current date in
previous stage but by the way if I say
second Tuesday next Tuesday if I just do
that do we get the right thing yeah
should magnificent okay so let's say
second Tuesday of May oops
help if I didn't say second nanosecond
oh my god yeah um second Tuesday of May
this is not looking good well I think
it's going to give the results since
there's not okay well I mean we don't
lose that many points for that that
wasn't that horrible yeah I think the
slight delay was that it was checking
for the Wolfram language representation
and checking for the result yeah that
kind of rules of signal something of a
Mansour last Friday of a month for
example it's there are loading the time
zones specifications where they say for
example the tanks on daylight saving
will occur the last Sunday of this month
or that other month so there's a whole
scheduling notation for holidays other
things yeah I mean I think we need to
look at that notation okay this needs to
come back another time
I think this stuff is implementable but
this needs to come back another time
yeah for that notation and what what is
the status of you actually working on
this neck in terms of the the more
complicated scheduling notation or being
able to do on dates in general on dates
in general I'm working on it actively
we're we're ramping up the big work that
I've been doing on updating the the
quantity implementation for the next
version which should get merged in a
couple days and we're doing some of the
things we've talked about dates in the
the past few meetings writing time
objects oh okay and what about the
temporal logic stuff and the you know
time after and so on so that we've we've
been continuing some of the discussions
and our weekly dates meeting with Jose
we're still that's still largely in the
design phase of figuring out what the
language representation of it's gonna be
and how we interact with things okay
okay good all right well so we made some
progress on this today mm-hmm good okay
all right so I think that's it for that
let's see we are over time but I think
we should let's at least try to you know
um go through a few of these more of
these things yeah so the empty suggests
young this is a suggesting of having a
function which can identify what the
meaning of emptiness of an expression
which is empty it's problematic because
the immediate question is whether this
is structural so it means length zero or
it's more like horrendously complicated
well where did it come from we have a
developer empty queue and some of our
developers in-house find that quite
useful so they suggested that we promote
it to system but of course immediately
we started suggesting or complaining
about the various problems that idea I I
don't see it I mean I think it's a I
mean I just don't see it what is an
empty an empty list I mean what are some
things we might consider we might
consider
so we have suggestions like empty graph
so empty list I mean what are the actual
expressions empty queue of a list empty
queue what is an empty sparse array well
all our definitions of arrays will
immediately convert into empty lists to
have a unique representation of it so
special array of that thing you have
there when converting to an empty but
this will not that yes that we know
that's just a bunch of zeros right
correct um okay but sparse array of
nothing like this does that also
normalize I think if you give us a
lengthy did you give serum come on
length is zero then as the length then
no doubt Lenny will certainly okay it
does that exactly but you see it doesn't
have had special ray anymore that's what
I meant weird yeah okay so it's empty
queue of the empty string supposed to be
right so Romans was was suggesting that
empty cube would do would know about the
different types and then it would say
two in this case because it know what to
do what's another string what other
kinds of things can I be I mean empty
empty audio object right things like
empty graph for example graph of of
empty list of what about the following
possibility this with a bunch of options
is that still an empty graph right that
says it's structural versus semantic
question so I I do find this problematic
but we wanted to check with you well I
mean who is who is championing this
particular thing I think Roman Roman
start discussion and he was suggesting
no he's not here okay let's let's can we
get a specific list of things we think
is supposed to be empty easy patterns we
think is supposed to be empty
okay I mean I also wonder a little bit
how this relates to the type system I
mean an empty you know each one of these
things yes yes so it could be natural to
have a second argument which says this
I'm considering emptiness of this
particular type I think this is curving
down a slippery slope test for that if
you want to write to me that the most
problematic thing is the structural
versus semantic thing like like in the
same way that we'll have function like
real Q so do we mean the types
structural type or I don't think this is
America I mean you could try to send it
back to Roman ask for a list of what he
thinks the patterns of emptiness are
supposed to be okay okay we we are
really over time here but I mean do you
want to take a few minutes to look at
this is that going to be useful or does
this going to really be require a longer
discussion well it took quite a long
time last time we went through these
though there is a main question there
which is this thing in red which is one
of the things that I find more difficult
to design which is how to express
relative errors versus absolute errors
because a standard way people do it is
like adding plus 33% but of course
because not normal of 33% will give 0.33
then it gets converted into a number and
we have these ambiguity of whether we
mean actually 0.33 we have to say scale
I think we all have a scaled wrapper
there it's scaled right now how to
converts into the absolute surprises
that's wrong I think what we need to do
is to have a notation in the plus/minus
thing then indicates that it's a
relative error I see so we talk about
what that is right so we keep for scaled
and if it is a relative error is Michael
here I don't know what no here's some
video
sorry what was the answer to the Michael
Mike Michael he's not here he saw video
okay um okay
so I mean my feeling is because Michael
would quote the the standard somehow
maybe you can throw at the standard I
mean it's there any I I don't think it's
right to convert this scale things to
absolute this is I think we have to
maintain them okay and because I think
that it is useful if you are doing it so
one question is if you combine something
with an absolute error with something
with a scale there are what do you get I
would say absolute errors this is more
like for representation but if you
combine two things with scale there as
what you get my tendency is also
absolute errors so somehow perhaps we
need a way of forcing they did the
representation the relative
representation back do we have we had
some kind of a round form didn't we we
discussed about it but we don't have it
yet yeah this may be one of those cases
in which we need right one for um so
yeah okay so the question then is the
display of plus minus thirty three
percent right you know in other words
how do we that's standard in the in the
literature to represent something with
the percentage error okay but but I
think we need a decoration here did we
not agree that the error is going to be
in smaller font we discussed that last
week yes so I'm not sure we agreed on
anything finally but we consider several
ideas I thought we were we'd agreed that
we were going to use a smaller font for
the error
I mean I mean we didn't agree agree but
there was something which was strongly
just mentioned and I think you also
mentioned us to take it to design so
okay yeah where am i storing these
things uncertainty so so then I think
the first thing I'm going to do is to
avoid scale getting out to convert it
yes and then we proceed from there to
see how hard works well hold on just a
minute let me just um what was the one
from last week is this uncertainty
examples oh oh five I think I'm putting
this in oh six okay but but but could we
maybe maybe Jeremy could join us for a
minute if we can find him and we could
talk about this design thing Davis
you
um I have to open some prototype build
right yes the functionalities in the
prototype cool okay this was our notes
from last time so the asymmetric case
already has this okay so this is what we
discussed is looking that's right
yes and Michael like that too okay so
now what we have to do is the relative
error what does the relative error look
like right yes
so the standard thing to do is to
two-percent it with a percentage fine
but putting a period behind the percent
it's definitely a loser well this is
following their dead two significant
digits rule I know that but it shouldn't
have a it shouldn't have a period there
should be 33% because that's the two
significant digits not 33 dot
imeem that looks really weird
the 33 dot but I think the question is
whether it's confusing
I guess if this is in a smaller font
then it becomes less confusing I mean
okay I don't know if I can do this here
but but but let's say it's 25 and
Jeremy's here um plus minus let's say
it's 33% and then that 33% is smaller
why isn't that going smaller well there
we go okay so that's smaller and maybe
it's gray or maybe it's got a um that's
probably not terrible I mean that's
reasonable and then and then the
alternative would be we're talking about
Jeremy numbers with errors yeah um so
tighter probably to the equal plus minus
what do you mean
just a little it's a little spaced a
little too far away but smaller is good
just a little tighter in the letter do
you think we should Center it I think we
think we should send to this or do you
think it should be to the baseline like
two pixels there I can I could take a
look
probably Center I'm sure as font size
gets bigger it's gonna look better
centered you know how to move this to
somebody remember how to do the AG how
do you do the like a baseline shift yeah
yeah but but how do I do what is it I am
trying to do a nudge how do I do not did
we take that out of the has to be in a
box an adjustment box first and then you
can nudge it even right but I thought we
had a way of doing nudge where is that
typesetting stuff where's all the stuff
to do with Enter Oh typesetting there we
go
now jump nudge down oh well that's a bug
well that's about
okay okay okay I clicked on my job okay
and the thing went bonkers okay um in
particular well it did do a baseline
shift but then somehow the payload
disappeared okay in any case and I
wonder if we should go gray or not
bother well you think we should go
vertically which got a little tighter
and for this relative error where we
have a percent so we'd say scale to 0.33
whatever it is but the print form will
be 33% correct
Jose yes exactly okay um the other issue
is that we would like to distinguish
this plus/minus Jeremy from the
plus/minus that we enter with escape
plus minus okay
it's kind of a mess perhaps precisely
the size defect it is smaller yeah I
think that will certainly help and that
suggests that the plus/minus also be
smaller in addition to the and there's
also a case Jeremy where where these
things are where this case here comes up
whether asymmetric errors which I think
it's distant and and that that argues
for centering for the for the single
plus mine yeah and a little bit of
lightning like a little gray make sense
do fine well that seems to have the
right tightness to it yeah okay why
don't you just spec what this should be
and Jose can implement that um is there
any other formatting issue that we have
here I mean we've got the case of what
are we doing with the case where we have
around with with some more complicated
argument structure like the correlation
matrix it's not being formatted when
when it gets very complicated and there
are many numbers it stays without
formatting okay fine we
discuss the other cases you remember the
Avogadro number in which people put in
parentheses oh yes that's the other case
right that's the other case so that was
part of the around forum right exactly
that's where we were discussing around
fund to control those things and here
yeah it's right above there no this was
my suggestion right this was my
suggestion for what to do yes we had the
example before this entity call if you
called it up right there yes I was
presenting that in parentheses right
which turns out Jeremy I had been going
all these years thinking that that meant
the 74 was the next two numbers here
okay okay turns out I don't know well
here's what it is it is a plus minus
error for the 57 isn't that wild that's
multiplication with a but no no no no no
it's this okay it's those last two
digits the 57 the 5-7 that's there those
digits are uncertain and so what it
really is is plus minus 0.000000 then
those digits okay right which is I mean
I'm I'm totally embarrassed that like
all these years I mean not that I've
ever needed to use this but all these
years I just got it wrong what I what it
was
um so what I was proposing was
this kind of approach where we basically
gray out um yeah we use a round form to
specify how we want this done and that
could also control the percentage you
know for scaled things but what I'm
suggesting is that the digits which are
uncertain are somehow grayed out and
paired where the plus/minus for those
digits sir I'm saying yeah I mean it's I
like what's below a little better where
the numbers aren't scaled it somehow
implies it's different than a
continuation of that fraction all right
when they're small like that
the 5/7 okay the problem is
um problem is that the um well that it's
nice to fuzz them out in gray I don't
disagree about that but that 24 just
looks totally crazy there why is it
narrow well if it's plus minus and it
was great to hit connect the greater we
connect to the gray it's the plus/minus
considered it's always that plus minus
is always going to be gray yeah so how
does one not right so you need to see
there's something else yeah by the time
we've got parens then we're in a bizarre
situation mean so so let's just look at
that case um country he'll next to 7b of
largest font but still three and then -
okay well let's try that case right -
the problem with that
the problem with that is that our usual
notation there means plus or minus 47
not plus or minus ok so here's another
possibility which maybe it's too weird
ok here's another possibility this and
we say plus minus dot dot dot 47
I mean I think it's fairly clear there's
a slight problem with the fact that I
mean so so this will always be after a
decimal point right this is never going
to end up being to the left of the
decimal point I believe is that correct
well we can have very large numbers as
well with Paris we were discussing
having automatic scientific notation for
that yeah I think that's what we have to
do which means that they will always be
to the right of the decimal point right
by the way on the live stream
Adam de bris amy is asking not all
absolute errors can be represented as
relative errors can they well we could
have sido plus minus something perhaps
that's right right which is hope which
is cannot be a relative error right
right but so what
where well the only point that's making
is a round form better not have if a
round form says show these as relative
errors the case of 0 plus minus 0.1 is
hopeless right that's similar to what we
get when we have a number that has what
is it no accuracy what am I thinking
about I'm saying yes yes we we have ever
missed sometimes when we require too
much precision or too much accuracy for
numbers that do not have it right but so
that means in particular what we do
there and it's not irrelevant to what
we're talking about here let's consider
the case how do i generate one of these
I would say think we have examples
impossible issues of a number form of
number form okay
you can write also when do you refer to
this cereal bucket aquatic -1 for
example well that's too extreme well
let's take a look at that case yeah that
case is notice it's pinked right and it
says no significant digits are available
to display that's the case where we
basically said the precision of the
number that that would happen even if it
wasn't a zero at the beginning there
right if we say one backtick backtick
minus one will get the same result
right and this is independent of number
four this is this is a property of the
number itself right the number itself
has no precision exactly yeah so that's
what I'm where I'm say these two
extremes I think here we have exactly
here we have error messages for numbers
which are correct just we are requesting
something consistent the precision is
small well I think it's a slightly
different case but this okay in any case
this look basic bottom line okay let's
go back to this idea here is this idea
crazy I think it's understandable I was
a bit concerned with the Faculty of
using dots but looks busy to me that's
my only the artistic content there's
just a lot going on there wish it was
simpler I mean even parens to me is a
cleaner version of that same case how
would we do the parens like above I mean
before 57 and after 47 yeah like that
business right but but in the format we
talked about for the other case so great
yeah all right so let's look at that
let's look at that idea okay so you're
proposing there that we would do this
and we would parenthesize there yeah
Graper and yeah but what would happen I
mean it's gonna be a little weird
because these parens that per n which we
could make gray let's just put it in
there um
that's a big paren and that's a little
paren so what we do we make that paren
smaller bigger
I mean it's unfortunately big I think
we're good to do the other one bigger
other other bracketing things we could
do like square in square brackets it is
nice that the parens here remind one of
the standard way to do this if they were
thin enough I think they'd look good I
agree that the standard ones at that
font size look way too big and well I
mean obviously this font size and the
real font size cuz we are typically
it'll look better it like a normal font
fight fine
well let's let's try mocking this up and
see whether you can give Jose a spec for
how to implement this okay um but so
then let's just understand the
consistency here so the consistency is
normally the only thing that's gray is
the stuff to the right-hand side of the
plus minus the plus minus cents
right-hand side because that means apply
the plus minus to the whole number in
this case the gray starts inside the
main number and we're indicating with
parens which part of the main number so
we got double indication of which part
of the main number is being arif I'd so
to speak is uncertain which seems okay
to me I mean in other words it's just
it's some um
um yeah I mean I think the real issue is
can we make the parens not look like
this number because we don't have any
other case where you would insert a sort
of a something like a diacritical mark
or something in in the in the number I
mean the only other case we have is like
recurring decimals and things where we
have bars over them someone on the
livestream is suggesting put in plus
minus below or above the 57 I I think
that's not going to work I think that's
gonna make a big mess because basically
it's usually quite important when we
have a raise of numbers that the things
have a fixed height um well is there any
alternative we can see I mean is there
any is the only way to save this idea
and using other characters that look
like the parents that are yeah what I
mean look the concern that I'm having is
breaking the number because one feature
of numbers by the way is that numbers
have fixed width every character is a
fixed width so for example one thing
that will break if we do this is if you
have a column of numbers please don't
send things okay if you have a column of
numbers
um the
um it won't align anymore in other words
if you've got that paren and if I have a
column of numbers right now numbers vary
in every reasonable font of fixed width
so that you know columns align making
sense but as soon as we put this mark in
the middle of the number it's not going
to align unless we somehow can make that
mark be essentially between the digits
that make sense
well it would go off by the time it hits
the plus/minus in a scaled font it's
gonna be off anyway so you've kind of
lost connection at that you know at the
408 it's all lined and after that you
know no matter what we're doing there's
gonna be some misalignment I think just
well it's misaligned after you hit the
plus/minus it's not necessarily the
digits not necessarily misaligned but
we're just you know we're saving two
digits here and we know we're gonna mess
it up at some point anyway it feels like
we're not gaining much by saving those
two right but okay so my question is can
we save this in any way is there any way
because that
honestly the paren I mean one reason I
like the paren is it is reminiscent of
the notation that I've uh turley failed
to understand for probably thirty years
or something since it first came in um
which is super embarrassing worked any
other fuzzy types here who
yeah III did okay
how did you know it because I've seen it
in the Avogadro's number it's more less
than diving how did you learn I think
that came in that notation came in
sometime around the late 80s or
something well I was thinking in Jordan
suggesting with dots what if we put zero
point ten dots and then for the sign so
it follows that they take the standard
full number strong everything and then
we can have different types of dots
there because they what I'm confused
about dots versus standard distinct dot
this doesn't help Jeremy's busyness
problem it doesn't in is this ever and
these are always integers the plus/minus
just because to the right-hand side of
the decimal point
yeah and relative to the what's gray on
the other side okay yeah I don't think
that's gonna work
look I think this is our best chance
let's let's see if we can get decent
mock-ups of this and go with that and
then go with the gray thing here and go
with a with a pure the only clue that
this is a relative error is that as a
percent sign right do we agree there's
no different graying parenthesize in or
anything like that okay
all right do we need to know me for
anything else here you can continue some
other day I mean this is just reviewing
more well let's do a little bit of quick
stuff here so here this section is about
independent data and the next one is
data with correlation so that's the
difference
yeah so a round replace here is turns
out my totally trivial correct in this
case yes it's what do you expect this
will be equivalent to exponent
of their own otherwise known is just
using replace here
or replace all rather yes in this case
is would be a same yes okay so let's see
where does it get different for example
if you have two cases then they may be
independent or they may be correlated
it's it's what we were discussing the
the the previous week with Russia the
difference between around Plus around
and two times around yes because our own
Plus around will assume they are
independent well two times around it
knows that a single one which is
multiplied by two right so this case is
what you're talking about so in this
case the main point is to put in okay so
this is our way of inserting two
identical tagged arounds exactly in
those places so the alternative approach
which I think we were sort of implicitly
discussing is which I'm not advocating
is every around has a UUID and you
compare you you IDs to find out whether
you think that they are correlated
arounds on non correlator rounds right
is that in fact obviously completely
bonkers to do that so in other words if
if every around I mean this is a way so
this is assuming that what you have that
you're always gonna generate this I mean
you could imagine having a key to for
every around and simply having the you
know and the question every time you do
a computation is to the keys agree if
the keys agree they're correlated
arounds I mean there are only two cases
that were considering that correlated or
they're not correlated correct
oh sure here by the way he yes well it's
not true and false only we will have in
general a matrix of correlation which
which is able to
to interpolate the two cases so there
are correlation factor factors yes but
so wait a minute so how I see that's
this case here right oh goody ugh okay
so your your point then is that the only
way to do this is to have I mean we
couldn't do that so my model of you you
IDs is basically blown up by this case a
true statement yes well we still would
have the difference between x and y
which could be represented with 2 XS yes
if we have a UUID it has to be in the
variables not in they around themselves
yeah which means that we don't gain
anything cuz we still have to have the
variables exactly so we might as well
call them x and y instead of UUID blar
and UUID bla right okay so this allows
us to get those two variables with that
so if i if i mess around with if i take
that expression and i mess around with
these by putting some some let's say I
put a big correlation there what happens
well this has to be a symmetric matrix
and the fact that it's so large may be I
think these coefficients are typically
smaller than okay so symmetric matrix
means that has to be let's say I put a
point to the another point to there
right interesting
how do we so the fact that there has to
be a symmetric matrix do we do we allow
a structured matrix and a structure
array I'm not sure I do right now but
certainly it will work it should work
yes it or sparse array it's in the case
of of three variables there do we end up
where I wind up just from the three by
three matrix right yeah but if we have
higher order correlations then we end up
with a tensor yes
yes it's correct it's what we were
saying there the previous week we accept
up to fourth moments so which I have up
to a race of Frank four okay but those
arrays of rank for our arrays with
certain symmetry properties yes so they
don't have as nearly as many independent
components excellent yeah but we're
still representing them as temps arrays
here yes but we could use a symmetry
array with only the independent
components okay um
that seems useful to do okay so the
question here is what is the question
here so the question here is do we
believe in this way of doing correlation
then I think this is pretty neat
actually I mean we'd worked this out a
while ago it looks quite sensible I mean
these are complicated cases where there
are correlated errors and so on you know
I don't know to what extent people will
really use this I mean I think that they
are very important for example the
examples further down on the exam
document in most cases they use this
fair enough I understand that I'm asking
in kind of lazy folk I said oh so if
you're lazy and you just say exponential
of around a blah plus exponential
another around those two rounds will be
treated as uncorrelated right exactly
yeah so worst case is you get too much
error correct or too little how can you
get too little because when they are
correlated they have a tendency to adapt
so so it's the differences they should
outer bound like inner borders well this
is not interval arithmetic so with with
coral with uncorrelated cases we
typically get square roots of sums of
squares these are related errors we get
directly to do I see okay yes okay with
and currently
the terrorists the error gets multiplied
by random walk in its a directed walk of
it if it's a correlated error exactly
yeah there's a standard term for this
model of approximate arithmetic I think
I don't remember what it is okay but
okay um okay so what's the story here
let's see well I just wanted to show the
way we handle correlations that's not a
wait wait wait wait wait wait this is
what the heck is this that what is that
what is this form here this is go ahead
so these case is separating the it's
doing the same computation as the
previous one but rather than giving the
full matrix originally is giving the
diagonal elements plus then they some
sort of normalized matrix this is
another way people specify the T
correlations by the way just to respond
to a question on the live stream where
could around be used while random
variables cannot there yeah this is this
is that this is a problem with the fact
that these live streams end up jumping
into our sort of working meetings in the
middle of long streams of discussion
this is the the position of the thumb
and this notebook indicates there was
quite a lot that came before the basic
answer to that question just to respond
to it is that there's a probability
distributions are fine if you know them
and if you're prepared to work through
them this is dealing with a variety of
approximations that are extremely you
know that are the only practical thing
to do for working with experimental data
with errors and you don't you you don't
even know the actual genuine dua
precisely have a Gaussian distribution
or a Weibull distribution or whatever
else this is dealing with the case where
you don't know that and you don't want
to work through the full details of
shattering the probability distribution
with lots of pieces and all that kind
thing anyway but but but back to this
some um back to this so again I'm sorry
this this is if I just want to give icy
to to come a point to so this is the
notation that she have like the means to
standard deviations and then the
correlation matrix in the advanced when
we had we had the 0.2 squared you know
that's a covariance matrix so there to
you know to equivalent waste you to look
at that one matrix is standardized to
have ones of the diagonal and the other
and the other one has you know the
standard deviations variance is really
there so this is this is in in a way
that's you know two two ways to look at
okay when you're dealing with
multivariate distributions like multi
normal distributions do we also set
things up with both of these
possibilities they're only for their for
the two-dimensional case so you when you
when you have a multi normal
distribution we have general covariance
matrix when you have a by normal
distribution for ease of life we allow
to have you know reached of means these
of list of standard deviations and then
the correlation coefficient okay so hold
on a second so this here this is just a
covariance matrix yes so we have the
mean vector which would be our values
and then the covariance matrix which
would be corresponding to their matrix
so the least and yes okay so this case
here where there's a variance and then a
correlation matrix that corresponds to
you by normal distribution but that
that's only limited to the two
dimensions and so in okay so wait a
minute so what we're doing in the Y is
by normal that's I see so in the case of
distributions you're saying we have a
differently named distribution for the
case where we're giving the covariance
matrix versus giving a correlation it's
so multi normal distribution can take
any dimension normal its it specifically
to and normal its specifically one
yes I get it I get it but I mean in the
case of these numbers with errors what
Jose is saying is that we can in
principle have you know three numbers
here
you know three-dimensional and
three-dimensional case and we can either
deal with having a covariance matrix
which is a three by three covariance
matrix or if I'm understanding correctly
we can have something in this form where
we have a length three vector of
variances of standard deviations
realizations yes followed by a
correlation matrix yes okay so what I'm
asking is is there an analog of that in
our distribution no for the three
dimensions you you need to use the multi
normal distribution it's for the reason
that you have the correlation
coefficients you know like Row one to
row and three row to one and then how
would you you know put them in in
orderly fashion in a vector it requires
some ordering and so for therefore the
for this for the sake of clarity and
enemy ambiguity you use multi normal
distribution for higher dimensions so a
little confused here because my
understanding is Jose is is claiming
that in a round you can give three
variables three-dimensional thing with a
list of variances followed by a
correlation matrix it's converted it's
yeah it's very similar so I don't have
an example but that matrix for the two
dimensional case can also be a single
number row like exactly like added by
normal distribution so these are just
different notations that people use no
no I understand that but what I'm saying
is for example if we want something
which converts from our round set up to
an approximating distribution right it
would be nice to have something which
has you know which has a lossless way of
going back and forth where it is
recording the you know the error
specification in the same form so to
speak
you see which suggests go show that
there may be some way of representing
essentially the multi normal
distribution using this type of you know
instead of giving because it is in fact
unambiguous I mean if you were to give
you a capital Sigma for your multi
normal distribution in this form right
but you know in a way it's inefficient
because you give a matrix and you could
give a covariance matrix and in here you
give a vector and then you give a matrix
so it's some reason we think it's worth
having here because people independently
think of the of the standard deviations
from the correlations yes sometimes it's
easier to think in terms of them
separately because you understands that
this one's rather than the numbers but
it's not a fundamental extension right
hey listen we should wrap this meeting
um several of us have the meeting about
quantum stuff in only about seven
minutes which will also be live
streaming so those on the live stream if
you're interested in watching that
please come back um I think we should
wrap this meeting and we need to
continue with us around stuff and how
much more do we have do we have half an
hour an hour or what do we think we have
it's not much more it just a few more
examples so the most complicated things
were this scale then in the typesetting
so I think we have advanced that today
and the rest are examples examples of of
things okay
from books and other things that
complicated case complex numbers
yes complex numbers are implicit idiom
we need to think about that that
notation is pretty cruddy if we're gonna
do that we got to have parens there
somehow right yeah all we've got to have
which I think will be better and I don't
know what the standard say about it plus
minuses for the real part and the
imaginary part separately what does that
not work because of correlation stuff
yeah it's all have to think about it
it's because these numbers are exactly
but that's a that's thing we have to
discuss I mean I I'm guessing this is
gonna need parens yeah um okay and and
go sure can we can we exercise a little
bit of thought in that question whether
we need a different format to be
supported for the distribution stuff to
allow kind of round-tripping sure okay
all right let's wrap this meeting and
see see some of you in just a few
minutes